hey guys it's Thursday I'm chastity I'm
Cali dan and Jess are out but we're here
with your news roundup first up we have
a new single-player campaign trailer for
Star Wars Battlefront 2 the new trailer
showcases some of what we can expect
from battlefront 2 single-player
campaign the Emperor orders Admiral iDEN
versio to ignite the inferno referring
to the Inferno squad a Special Forces
Group the death star 2 is then destroyed
but rather than crushing the Empire it
causes the Inferno squad and company to
lash out against the rebellion there are
some glimpses of space battles and a
chase with the Millennium Falcon we also
see appearances by Luke Skywalker Leia
and Maz Kanata aside from the
single-player campaign a lot of
discussions surrounding the game has
focused on its microtransactions loot
crate's and star cards battle fronts who
will give away things like maps and
character dlc for free but it will use a
loot box style system for unlocking
various upgrades leading some fans to
accuse the system of being pay2win in an
interview with GameSpot a I said
people's fears are understandable at the
same time calling the accusations hard
to dodge Chris Matthews art director at
EA motiv said dice has taken great care
to make sure that the star cards and the
way they work give you more options in
battle terms like pay to win and stuff
like that are hard to dodge but the guys
are doing a really incredible job of
trying to balance that system
battlefront 2 releases for ps4 Xbox one
and PC on November 17th and according to
a producer at motive studios a Nintendo
switch version hasn't been ruled out
speaking of which Nintendo's switch just
got a big update that adds gameplay
capture save data transfer and more I
for one I'm very excited about this
because the switch is quickly becoming
my most used console and I can rest easy
knowing my 150 hours all the safe isn't
trapped on my switch forever with the
4.0 update applied you'll be able to
hold down the capture button and record
the previous 30 seconds of gameplay this
currently only works with certain games
including breath of the wild splatoon to
Arms and Mario Kart 8 deluxe sort of but
we'll get to that in a bit you'll be
able to edit and post the clips the way
you would screenshots the other major
new feature is the ability to transfer
save data to a new switch similar to how
it works for 3ds is once you transfer
the data it'll be erased from the first
switch users have also discovered that
the update somewhat secretly adds
support for headphones through USB when
the console is docked including
Arlis ones just plug in the headphones
and the switch will automatically
recognize them I'd be a lot more excited
about this
if voice-chat were more readily
supported on switch but I'm not
complaining
finally the update adds more
customization and quality of life
improvements you can read the full patch
notes and more about the update right
now on GameSpot related to switch
updates there's a new one out from Mario
Kart 8 deluxe it enables the accra
mention gameplay capture and make some
tweaks to the dreaded blue shell with
the update the blue shell will no longer
target the second-place player if the
first place player hasn't yet crossed
the finish line this is either a nerf or
a buff depending on how good a racer you
are I mean yeah the blue shell shouldn't
hit the person in second place but it
also shouldn't hit me be sure to check
out our Star Wars Battlefront 2 campaign
impressions on gamespot.com and let us
know what you thought of today's stories
in the comments below we'll be back
tomorrow with your top 5 stories of the
week thanks for watching
related to switch updates there's a new
one out for Mario Kart 8 deluxe it
enables the after mentioned gameplay
capture and make some tweets tweets
related to switch updates there's a new
one
[Laughter]